it is breaking news, just
coming at CNN right now.
Meta, the parent company of
both Facebook and Instagram
says it is restoring the social
media accounts of former
president Donald Trump.
For more, that I want to bring
in done o'sullivan, and CNN
media analyst, Sara Fischer.
She is a senior media reporter
overt axios.
Let me start with you.
First of all, give us the
specifics.
What if you learned?
>> Well, this is the most
politically consequential
decision meta, Facebook's
parent company has ever made.
In the past few minutes, meta
announced that it is going to
allow former president Donald
Trump back on its platforms,
which of course include
Facebook and Instagram.
Trump was kicked off those
platforms in the days following
the capitol attack.
Facebook saying at the time
that having him there was a
risk to public safety.
Facebook said they would
reconsider the decision after
two years, which they did.
They decided at the risk to
public safety is not what it
was, in their view.
In January 2021, and now
they're putting him back on the
platform.
He's going to get his accounts
back in the coming weeks, but
wolf, the really important
thing for the trump campaign is
in previous campaigns, trump
has spent hundreds of millions
on targeted Facebook
advertising.
That is going to be very
important, as we go into 2024.
>> It certainly is, indeed.
There remains a lot of money in
advertising, as well.
Sarah, I know you had an
exclusive interview.
Tell us about that, he is the
president of global affairs for
meta.
What can you tell us about what
he reveal to you?
>> For one thing, wolf, he did
not talk to trump or any of his
associates before this
decision.
So they are learning about this
in realtime.
At the same time as CNN's
viewers are learning about
this.
They also did not talk to the
white house or any other
stakeholders.
We are all learning about it at
the same time.
A couple of other things to
note, he takes full
responsibility for this
decision, not mark is a coburg.
Part of the reason they
elevated him to that president
of global affairs role is so
that he could take some of that
responsibility and take the
heat off of Mark Zuckerberg.
And I think the last
consequential thing is that
there is going to be instances
where Donald Trump might post
something that doesn't
explicitly break their rules,
but they're going to want to do
something about it.
So meta has rolled out some new
things they are going to do to
take control of the situations.
For example, they might limit
the ability of a post to be
re-shared, but keep that post
up.
They also might say, all right,
Donald Trump, we're not going
to take your counts away.
We're not going to suspend them,
but you no longer can run ads.
That is a huge deal.
And so these are new things
that they're engineering teams
are going to have to
reconstruct, and wolf, that's
why they are not reinstating's
accounts today.
They're going to need some time
technologically on the back and
to build this out, before they
let him back on.
>> Kristen, how is trump
reacting to this breaking news?
>> Look, as there, said he was
not given a heads up, so the
people I'm talking to are very
happy, but we have yet to have
a formal statement from trump
world because they are learning
about this in realtime.
No one on trump's team was
contacted early, given an early
heads up.
They were contacted for a
meeting just before 5:00.
They are still, as what I'm
hearing, in that meeting.
They are still trying to
understand the details of what
this means for them.
On their end, what are the
restrictions exactly?
What does this look like?
But they are very excited.
As we reported last, week he
sent his letter to Facebook,
trying to expedite this
process.
A lot of this is about
financing.
They need that money going into
2024, and they have complained
that being off Facebook has
stopped them from getting new
donors.
From picking up donors, from
advertising in trump's voice,
which again, leads to more
money and leads to donors,
instead era.
This is something they are very,
very much looking forward to.
The other thing I want to point
out here, we know that he has
already been reinstated on
Twitter, but it is likely that
you are actually going to see
him tweet in the near future.
We know, and this is from
sources around trump world,
that he has been workshop in
what his first tweet might be.
Members of his campaign asking
outside advisers, what do you
think it would look like if
trump got back on Twitter?
And of course, he still has his
own platform, and there are
legal implications there.
But it does sound more and more
likely we are going to see him
active on Twitter, as well.
>> He used to be very active on
Twitter with his millions of
followers.
How did Facebook --
you've got some more specifics.
How did Facebook wind up making
this important decision?
>> Yeah, like many things with
Facebook and their explanation,
it's a bit wishy-washy.
They claim that they put in
place a kind of framework that
we've learned about in the past
few weeks, where they consider
it quite subjective.
Is Donald Trump on our platform
to a threat to public safety?
We are still going through
meadows exact reasonings on all
of that, but it doesn't seem to
be particularly clear.
Obviously, there are other
considerations as they made
this decision, as well.
I think what is quite notable
here, Sarah just mentioned the
name mark is a coburg.
The person who runs this
company has kind of given Nick
play they --
who lost his election in the uk
in 2017, a failed politician.
He gave this huge power, trying
to be the fall guy to take this
decision.
This is taking a lot of heat
off of Zuckerberg myself.
>> How dramatic is this
decision?
>> It's huge, wolf.
It has implications that are
broader than just U.S.
Politics.
You will recall that Facebook
has taken action on other world
leaders.
Bolsonaro, in Brazil, when he
was denouncing covid vaccines.
And so what this means is that
moving forward, Facebook is not
going to be the same type of
public square that maybe
Twitter is.
Which has much more relaxed
content policies under Elon
Musk.
They are going to take a much
more cautious approach.
The other really important
thing about this decision is
that they are going to change
the way that they think about
content that is considered
newsworthy.
In the past, a criticism of
silencing Donald Trump has been
well, doesn't the public
deserve to know if he said